How do I address frequent night urination?
Well frequent night urination for a male is
typically due to
prosthetic enlargement.
So prosthetic enlargement can be what's called benign
prosthetic enlargement, meaning that it's not due to cancer. So if you don't have prostate cancer
but you are getting up and going to the bathroom, you know, five times a night,
it can be because you're not completely
empty, you're bladder and yet you're getting the sensation that you have to pee and it's waking you up
so you're waking up to go to the bathroom and you're not completely empty, you're bladder because
your prostate is enlarged, pinched, on the exit of that urine. So
you have
uritors that come from your kidney down to your bladder and then your bladder goes
has a tube called your urethra that goes down to empty into the toilet but it passes through your
prostate. Prostate is enlarged then you
it will block that so you won't get full emptied of your bladder.
Number two reason why you could get
having to go to the bathroom all the time can be because of blood sugar issues. So people with
diabetes tend to have to get up and go to the bathroom a lot or in a pre-diabetic state.
So getting checking your blood sugar, getting a simple
glucometer to check your blood sugar would be a good idea to make sure that you're not in a
pre-diabetic state because that could be a possibility of why you're having to get up to go to
the bathroom. Number three, so again, how do you address frequent diet urination? You try to
address the cause. So I said benign prostatic hypertrophy would be one cause. Prostate cancer with
with increased size of the prostate would be another cause. Talking males there only.
Pre-diabetic or diabetes would be a third cause, both males and females.
Fourth cause could be an urinary tract infection. So urinary tract infections can cause that because
you got inflammation at your rethra many times in the bladder. That can cause that issue.
You can, as we age, another condition that's not very commonly spoken about is what's called
a tipped bladder. Very common with women with a tipped uterus, the bladder and the uterus will
all tip forward. If it tips forward, it's hard to show you without using my hand signals that I'm
using right now that you can't see. But if the bladder tips forward, then it can pocket like a
little pocket of the anterior or front side of the bladder where it doesn't empty because the
urethra that is the tube that empties the bladder is now tipped backwards. It is higher
than a little bulge of the bladder. So you're never really emptying the bladder completely.
So a tipped bladder, with women, it goes with a tipped uterus is another issue. I used to do
that technique where you tipped the uterus back and tipped the bladder back. I don't think I have a
video of that. Maybe I should make a video, create a video because you can do it to yourself,
but you can have somebody do it to you. And that could bring, that could possibly bring a lot of
relief. So you're trying to figure out the cause. Whenever you're saying, okay, I have this symptom,
well, what could that symptom be, you know, what could be causing that symptom so you could treat
the cause of that. So those would be the most common things. And, you know, drinking, you know,
being excessively hydrated before you go to bed, some simple things like that could be other causes,
but trying to dig to figure out that cause would be the answer. To know if you have a possible
urinary tract infection, you could actually, and I've recommended people do this, you could actually
go on Amazon, and you could get urine dipstick tests. Same literally, the same test that if you
went and got a blood test today, also did a urine analysis on you, and you had to give a urine sample,
they literally take those dipsticks test with strips, which you could buy them for maybe a dollar,
a test strip, or even less than that. Cause the little thing that you buy on Amazon, the test of
urinary strips, make sure you get the one with the most amount of tests on there, you dip it in
your urine, so you collect a urine sample, you dip that strip of the urine, and then you follow the
instructions on the little, the little cylinder that it comes with, and then you look at the colors
of each test against the cylinder itself, and you could tell if you have any possible, make sure
you get the one that has a bacteria test in it. So if you have an infection or a high glucose,
or something like that, you could get an idea of what's going on urinary tract-wise.